[Musique]
la plus atroce offense que l'on puisse
faire à un homme c'est de nier qu'il
souffre c'est en tant que jeune
chercheuse ayant consacré quelques
années de ma vie à utiliser la douleur
que je souhaitais partager avec vous
cette citation de césar pavese qui me
touche énormément
pourquoi parce qu'à mes yeux elle
représente une réalité où la victime est
le plus innocent des êtres humains c'est
à dire l'enfant en effet il ya moins de
30 ans alors que moi-même je n'étais pas
encore né
on y est la douleur des enfants et ont
considéré que les bébés et les jeunes
enfants étaient protégés par leur
immaturité que leur cerveau n'était pas
assez mature pour intégrer la douleur et
que même s'il ressentait de la douleur
il oubliera très vite de toute façon
alors à quoi bon s'embêter à leur donner
des antalgiques
pourtant les expériences douloureuses
que nous avons vécu dès notre plus jeune
âge ont beaucoup d' influence sur la
façon dont nous réagissons à la douleur
en tant qu'adulte mais avant de
comprendre comment se construisent les
circuits de la perception douloureuse
chez l'enfant
il nous faut d'abord comprendre comment
ça marche la douleur pour l'illustrer
prenons un exemple que vous et moi
connaissons bien imaginer que en vous
relevant de votre canapé vous vous
cogner le petit orteil contre le pied de
la table basse ça fait mal hein qu'est
ce qui se passe dans votre corps à ce
moment là et bien des récepteurs à la
douleur qui sont situés dans votre petit
orteil vont détecter cette information
douloureuse et vont la faire remonter
sous forme de signal électrique via les
nerfs de vos jambes jusque dans votre
moelle épinière
puis de la moelle épinière l'information
douloureuse va remonter jusqu'au cerveau
qui devient alors consciemment informer
que votre petit orteil lien d'être
malmenés bien sûr ce qui se passe dans
notre corps à ce moment là est beaucoup
plus complexe que ça
puisque nous disposons de mécanismes
très important qui entrent en jeu et
qu'on appelle les contrôles internes de
la douleur ont pour l illustrer en
quelque sorte par des portes qui tout au
long du parcours de l'information
douloureuse peut se fermer pour rendre
plus difficile l'accès de cette
information douloureuse au cerveau et
donc atténuer la douleur
j'imagine que comme moi votre premier
réflexe lorsque vous vous cogner le
petit orteil c'est d'abord du relais
toutes les insanités de la terre mais
ensuite de prendre votre pied entre vos
mains et de masse et le petit orteil et
bien cette réaction réflexe tout à fait
naturel permet de réduire la sensation
douloureuse en activant les contrôles
internes de la douleur résultat on a
moins mal alors maintenant qu'on a vu
comment fonctionne de manière générale
les circuits de la douleur chez l'adulte
il nous faut comprendre comment ces
circuits se construisent au cours du
développement de l'individu ce que l'on
a découvert au cours de ces vingt
dernières années c'est que le schéma de
la douleur se dessine progressivement au
cours de la vie intra utérine
en effet le premier récepteur à la
douleur apparaissent chez le foetus au
niveau de la cavité buccale à la
huitième semaine de grossesse
c'est-à-dire bien souvent avant même que
la future mère ne sache qu'elle est
enceinte puis ces récepteurs vont
s'étendre aux mains et aux pieds à la
dixième semaine de grossesse
l'ensemble du corps étant recouvert à la
20e semaine de grossesse et déjà dès la
26e semaine c'est à dire dès le sixième
mois de grossesse
les mécanismes de transmission de la
douleur sont opérationnels en 94
une étude visant à étudier les
conséquences de prélèvement sanguin
intra-utérin pour le dépistage de
maladies foetale a montré que des foetus
âgé de six à neuf mois s'agitait lorsque
les aiguilles étaient insérées dans leur
abdomen leur rythme cardiaque s'élevait
et on détectait une libération de
cortisol l'hormone de stress dans leur
organisme
ce qui est terrible c'est que avant de
comprendre l'existence de la douleur des
foetus
lorsque les bébés étaient nés grands
prématurés d intervention chirurgicale
cardiaque est essentielle à la survie de
l'enfant et nécessitant l'ouverture du
thorax était réalisée sans anesthésie
pouvez vous imaginer que dans les années
80 le seul traitement administré à ces
nourrissons étaient du curare paralysant
musculaire utilisé pour simplifier le
travail des chirurgiens
heureusement aujourd'hui c'est
impensable
pourtant de nombreux gestes qui peuvent
sembler être anodin pour nous en tant
qu'adulte mais qui sont très douloureux
pour les bébés pourraient encore être
évitée que ce soit les prises de sang
répéter dans le talent pour les tests
diagnostiques et les dépistages
systématiques ou bien la simple pose de
sparadrap sur la peau dont le retrait
est en général très douloureux d'autant
plus que si le cerveau des bébés est
assez mature pour intégrer la douleur il
ne dispose pas encore des contrôles
internes de la douleur et donc la
douleur va être perçue de façon beaucoup
plus intense parler bébé puisque rien ne
leur permet de l'atténuer et comme le
bébé n'a pas la notion du temps ni celle
du soulagement
il est très vite envahie par une douleur
c'est à dire que une douleur de courte
durée pour nous va être vécue par lui
comme une douleur prolongée et lorsqu
une douleur intense dure l'enfant change
de comportement il s'immobilise dans la
position la moins inconfortable pour lui
et devient indifférent au monde qui
l'entourent à ses parents a sans doute
vous il peut ainsi rester silencieux et
immobiles
tant que la douleur persiste
c'est en grandissant que l'enfant va
acquérir la capacité de contrôler la
douleur ou du moins d'apprendre à la
gérer d'ailleurs quand on s'intéresse au
développement de la douleur chez
l'enfant
il est intéressant de citer les travaux
de jean piaget un psychologue suisse des
années 1900 qui s'est beaucoup
intéressée au développement des
individus piaget a défini quatre grands
stades de développement
durant le premier stade qui correspond
aux deux premières années de la vie se
développe le système qui va permettre à
l'enfant de savoir où il a mal je
m'explique
l'enfant nouveau-né n'a pas conscience
des limites de son propre corps en tant
qu'individu ce sont les expériences
sensorielles et motrices
initié par ses besoins vitaux comme la
faim la soif la recherche de confort au
creux de ses parents qui vont permettre
à l'enfant de se définir en tant
qu'individu indépendant par exemple ce
n'est qu'à partir du quinzième mois que
l'enfant va prendre conscience que ses
pieds avec lesquels il joue comme un
hochet sont en fait une partie
intégrante de son propre corps à ce
stade la réponse à la douleur apparaît
sous forme de réflexes associé à la
colère ou à la tristesse rien d'étonnant
puisque les bébés n'ont pas de mots pour
exprimer qu'ils ont mal en dehors des
pleurs et il ne dispose pas non plus des
ressources leur permettant d'atténuer la
douleur c'est à dire que non seulement
ils ne comprennent pas la douleur mais
aussi il ne la contrôle pas et ne
l'anticipent pas non plus en se
soulageant eux mêmes comme nous les
adultes pourrions le faire par exemple
en nous menaçant le petit orteil
il ya ensuite le deuxième stade que l'on
rencontre de deux à sept ans à ce stade
l'enfant développe son langage et ça y
est il est capable de décrire la douleur
avec des mots heil bobo mal et à la
localiser de manière précise tête ventre
genou pied etc
par contre il n'arrive toujours pas à
faire le lien entre la cause et l'effet
je me cogne
donc j'ai mal en revanche ce qui est
intéressant avec l'enfant à ce stade
c'est qu'il peut être persuadé qu'une
douleur va pouvoir disparaître avec un
peu de poudre de perlimpinpin ou avec un
bisou malik
un peu plus tard on rencontre le
troisième stade de 7 à 11 ans à ce stade
l'enfant est capable de décrire la
douleur en termes précis et grande
avancée il est capable d'en quantifier
l'intensité c'est aussi à ce stade que
l'enfant prend conscience que l'attitude
qu'il adoptera lui permettra de soulager
voire carrément d'éviter une douleur par
exemple si je roule trop vite à vélo je
vais tomber m faire mal vient enfin le
quatrième et dernier stade que l'on
rencontre de 11 ans jusqu'à l'âge adulte
ce stade est caractéristique de
véritables raisonnement complexe de
capacité d'introspection de l'individu
de description de la pensée de
description de la douleur ça fait mal
comme comme une déchirure comme un coup
de poignard dans le ventre ça tire à ce
stade
l'adolescent prend conscience que
l'attitude psychologique qu'il adoptera
pour à interférer sur sa santé sur sa
maladie et sur sa douleur
il va acquérir la capacité de faire face
à la douleur en se persuadant qu'il peut
qu'il peut y faire face tout simplement
en renonçant à la douleur ou en y
prêtant pas attention
alors maintenant que je vous ai dit tout
ça vous pourriez penser comme le veut
une vieille idée populaire que un enfant
victime de douleurs intenses durant son
jeune âge s'endurcit et bien c'est faux
c'est même l'inversé qui se produit il
semble se produire un phénomène de
sensibilisation à la douleur mais dont
on ne comprend pas encore les mécanismes
pour vous donner un exemple la
circoncision et l'opération chirurgicale
la plus pratiquée chez les petits
garçons aux états unis avec une moyenne
de 60% des petits garçons circoncis à la
naissance
bien sûr selon les régions dans les
années 2000
cette opération chirurgicale et est
encore pratiquée sans traitement
antidouleur
pourtant il a été montré dès les années
90 que des petits garçons circoncis à la
naissance sans anesthésie pleurait plus
intensément
avec des modifications comportementales
et des perturbations physiologiques plus
grande lors de vaccination ultérieure
par rapport à des petits garçons
circoncis avec anesthésie et des petits
garçons qui n'avait pas été circoncis du
tout il semble donc se produire une
forme de mémoire de la douleur
autrement dit le système nerveux des
nouveau nés est capable de garder la
trace d'un évènement douloureux et ceci
même plusieurs mois après l'événement et
finalement ces petites traces de la
douleur vont à la longue ça cumulé pour
créer de larges empreinte de la douleur
pouvant induire de profondes
répercussions à l'âge adulte pouvoir les
par exemple de la peur du dentiste a la
phobie des piqûres à l'évitement des
consultations médicales et des
hospitalisations chose que bon nombre
d'entre nous ici connaît sans doute ce
que j'aimerais que vous reteniez sait
combien il est important de mieux
s'intéresser à la douleur des enfants
heureusement les travaux de recherche
réalisés au cours de ces 25 dernières
années nous ont permis de comprendre un
petit peu plus de choses sur la façon
dont se construit la douleur chez
l'enfant ce qui nous permet de mieux
l'appréhender et donc de mieux soulager
la douleur des enfants ce qui par
ricochet impact la vie de l'individu en
tant qu'adulte j'aimerais aussi attirer
votre attention sur le fait que certes
il existe des douleurs qui sont utiles
aux enfants les bosses les bleus les
égratignures et les petites coupures
vont permettre aux enfants d'apprendre
les limites de leur propre corps
d'apprendre les limites leur
environnement en revanche les douleurs
liées à la maladie
celle provoquée par une opération ou une
ponction lombaire n'ont jamais été une
étape nécessaire vers la maturité
il nous reste encore beaucoup de chemin
à faire pour soulager et éviter la
douleur des enfants et j'espère que les
travaux de recherches en cours et ceux à
venir nous permettront d'aller encore
plus loin pour que enfin un jour nos
enfants puissent pleurer pour rien je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]